aquí dice 1000 y tiene cinco dólares más
que james mil y tiene 33 dólares
cuánto tiene james vamos a usar unas
letras que representan la cantidad de
dinero que tiene mili y la cantidad de
dinero que tiene james digamos que la m
representa la cantidad de dinero que
tiene mili y que la jota representa la
cantidad de dinero que tiene james
entonces aquí dice que emily tiene 5
dólares más que james m que es la
cantidad de dinero que tiene 1000 y es
igual a la cantidad de dinero que tiene
james es igual a jota más 55 empezamos
con la cantidad de dinero que tiene
james + 5 y esto es igual a la cantidad
de dinero que tiene mil y mil y tiene 5
dólares más que james y nos dicen que
mil y tiene 33 dólares así que sabemos
que es igual a 33 esta oración que
tenemos aquí nos dice que m
es igual a 33 dólares y en lugar de
tener esta m aquí podemos escribir 33
dólares es igual a la cantidad de dinero
que tiene james es igual a jota + 5 y
ahora si podemos pensar en la cantidad
de dinero que tiene james cuanto tiene
james los invito a que pongan pausa en
el vídeo y que traten de resolverlo por
ustedes mismos
una manera de pensar en esto es dibujar
una recta numérica déjenme dibujar una
recta numérica de este lado y digamos
que aquí tenemos el cero y que en este
punto de aquí tenemos la cantidad de
dinero que tiene 1000 y entonces
escribimos m es igual a 33 y j que es la
cantidad de james la ponemos aquí y
sabemos que si le sumamos 5 a la
cantidad que tiene james obtendremos 33
entonces si empezamos aquí en la j y
sumamos 5 vamos a llegar a 33 pero ahora
pensemos de qué manera podríamos
comenzar con la cantidad que tiene 1000
y llegar a la cantidad que tiene james
bueno por lo hacemos de la manera
inversa
empezamos con m y restamos 5 restamos 5
entonces podemos decir que 33 que sm la
cantidad que tiene 1000
5 es igual a la cantidad de dinero que
tiene james así que ya podemos saber
cuánto tiene james 33 menos 5 es igual a
28 y podemos decir que 28 es igual a
jota o que james tiene 28 dólares y esta
jota de aquí es igual a 28 y lo podemos
ver aquí en la recta 28 más 5 es igual a
33 así que esta pregunta está resuelta
vamos a la siguiente pregunta la casa de
jessica está cinco veces más lejos que
la casa de paulette la casa de jessica
está a 15 millas de la escuela a qué
distancia de la escuela se encuentra la
casa de paulette y como lo hemos estado
haciendo antes tenemos que revisar cada
oración para entender bien lo que nos
están diciendo los ánimos que usan
algunas letras para representar la
distancia de la casa de jessica a la
escuela y la distancia de la casa de
paulette a la escuela y tratan de
resolver esto por ustedes mismos
bueno la j podría ser adecuada para
definir la distancia entre la escuela y
la casa de jessica y la p para
representar la distancia entre la
escuela y la casa de paulette lo que nos
dicen aquí es que si tenemos la
distancia que hay entre la casa de
paulette y la escuela cinco veces esa
distancia es lo que hay entre la casa de
jessica y la escuela entonces podemos
escribir p
qué es la distancia entre la casa de
paulette y la escuela por 5 por 5 es
igual a la distancia entre la casa de
jessica y la escuela y aquí nos dice la
casa de jessica está a 15 millas de la
escuela esencialmente lo que esta
oración nos dice esta oración de aquí es
que j es igual a 15 j es igual a 15
entonces podemos escribir esto que
tenemos aquí de la siguiente manera la
distancia entre la escuela y la casa de
paulette o sea p por 5 es igual a 15
ahora tenemos que saber cuánto vale t y
debemos encontrar un número que
multiplicado por 5 sea igual a 15
cuántas millas multiplicadas por 5 es
igual a 15 millas bueno podemos tener
ese número en la mente pero también
podemos verlo de la siguiente manera
fíjense bien voy a dibujar una recta
numérica de este lado y dibujo mi recta
numérica y si empezamos con este
pero con este número p este punto de
aquí es la distancia entre la casa de
paulette y la escuela y lo multiplicamos
por 5 aquí tenemos que por 1 por 2 x 3
por 4 y por 5 esta distancia es p aquí
hay otra distancia p aquí otra más esta
es otra vez la distancia p y otra vez la
distancia p otra manera de verlo es
considerar toda esta distancia como p
más p p más p más p
p por 5
por 5 y eso es igual a la distancia que
hay entre la casa de jessica y la
escuela entonces el punto de aquí es
igual a 15 lo que es lo mismo que j
ahora vamos a resolverlo si p por 5 es
igual a 15 es lo mismo que dividir 15
entre 5 partes iguales o 5 grupos
iguales entonces podemos decir que p es
igual a 15 dividido entre 5 grupos
iguales y si tenemos 15 millas y las
dividimos entre 5 grupos iguales eso va
a ser igual a p y vamos a tener el valor
de p entonces cuál es el resultado
si tenemos 15 y lo dividimos entre 5 el
resultado es 3 así que la distancia
entre la escuela y la casa de paulette
es igual a 3 millas y lo podemos ver
aquí tres más tres más tres más tres más
tres cinco veces tres es 15 la casa de
jessica que está a 15 millas de la
escuela está cinco veces más lejos que
la casa de paulette que está a tres
millas